اخيرا
ظهر الحق يا عادل
انه مش بس النساء اللي تصاب باكتئاب ما
بعد الولاده كلم
ظهر الحق لانه مثلهم مثل النساء مشاهدينا
الاباء الجدد ايضا يمرون بتغيرات مزاجيه
خطيره بعد ولاده طفل جديد طبعا وفق دراسه
نشرت في الجمعيه الطبيه الامريكيه اكتئاب
ما بعد الولاده الذي يصيب الامهات يصيب
ايضا الرجال في حاله نفسيه يصفها البعض
بالصامته
حوالي
عشره قبل ولاده طفلهم مباشره ويحدث بشكل
اكثر شيوعا بعد الولاده بثلاثه الى سته
اشهر اكتئاب الرجل ما بعد الولاده يعاني
واحد من كل اربعه رجال من اعراضه تلعب
الكثير من العوامل دورا في اصابه الرجال
نتعرف على هذه العوامل مع لميس ونرجع مره
ثانيه شفتي مظلومين
باكتئاب بعد الولاده
[موسيقى]
هرمونات الام تتغير كثيرا اثناء الحمل
وبعده لكن هناك ادله على ان الاباء يعانون
ايضا من تغيرات حقيقيه في مستويات
هرموناتهم بعد ولاده الطفل كما تلعب
الكثير من العوامل الغير الهرمونيه دورها
ايضا في اصابه الاب باكتئاب ما بعد
الولاده منها اهمال الام لزوجها وتركيز
اهتمامها مع الطفل ما يجعل الاباء يوصابون
بالاكتئاب احيانا الضغط النفسي بسبب مهام
الابوه الجديده على الرجل تجعل توتره
وخوفه يزداد حول الشؤون الماليه والمهنيه
قله النوم فمعظم الاباء والامهات الجدد
يحصلون على عدد ساعات اقل من النوم وهذا
يمكن ان يكون له تاثير على المزاج ومن
العلامات الاكثر شيوعا لاصابه الرجال
بالاكتئاب الغضب وفقد الاهتمام بالعمل
والانشطه المفضله والانسحاب من العائله
والاصدقاء ونحن سالنا الناس في الاردن
ومصر برايك لماذا قد يصاب الرجل باكتئاب
ما بعد الولاده نتابع الاجابات
بعد ما يجون مولود بتغيب تختلف حياته بصير
عنده زي مسؤوليه بصير يهتم اللي يودي
الدكتور بده يعالجه بصحى له بالليل بزعجه
هذا ايش الواحد بيتعود عليه شوي شوي بصير
اي شيء عادي طبيعه لبين ما يكبر الولد
ويصير يعني اموره تمام خلص ساعتها
باكتئاب انه يصير عنده مسؤوليه بده يربيه
بده يطلعه احسن ترباي بده يعلمه الصح من
الغلط بده يدرسه بده يطالعه منيح بالمجتمع
ومش اكتئاب هو
كانه عايش بحيره انه صار في عنده بيبي
جديد عنده مسؤوليه كبيره يعني بتفاجئ وهي
كلها راس مالها يعني اسبوعين لاربعين يوم
بتاقلم مع الجو واحد بيجي مولود
بتغيب عليه كل شيء يعني لما بكون عزابي
لما بيتجوز بيجي ولد
بتلاقيه يعني
حبابه بتعب الولد بضل اعيط بالليل يعني
الواحد بعرفش ينام بيتغيب عليه روتين
[موسيقى]
من عمان الاختصاصيه النفسيه ضحى العوامله
اهلا بك يا ضحى معنا في صباح العربيه
ضحى يعني معروف ليش صباح الفل
معروف ليش اكتئاب ما بعد الولاده يصيب
النساء نتيجه طبعا غير الظروف النفسيه
الصعبه والتغيرات الكبيره اللي بتمر فيها
المراه الحامل كمان في جانب هرموني طب
الرجال لما يصيبهم اكتئاب ما بعد الولاده
ما عندهم هرمونات
بالمراسله مثلا كيف ليش بصيبهم اذا ما في
اي تغيرات هرمونيه بجسدهم والله بتتفاجئي
يا راويه ويعادل انه بلا في تغييرات
هرمونيه بتصيب الرجل يعني خلال فتره حمل
زوجته وبالاخر لما تولد بيقل معدل
التستوستيرون عن معدل الطبيعي شوي في بعض
الدراسات وجدت هذا الشيء
يعمل تقلبات في المزاج بس الاهم من هيك
الاسباب اللي ذكرتوها وذكرتها لميس
بالتقرير انه اولا الهموم
عندي عيله وانا بدي اكون الشخص اللي يعني
المنتج اللي بعطي هاي العيله وبدير باله
على العيله فهذا القلق يعني هو سببه القلق
اكثر شيء كمان برضه اتباع تانيه ممكن برضه
هو يشوف زوجته انه لانها ام لانه هلا هي
كمان عم بتمر بتجربه جديده عم تهتم
بهالطفل الرضيع اللي مش عارف يعبر عن حاله
فشي طبيعي انه كل اهتمامها توشفت ويتغير
من العيله ومنهم هم كابل كزوج ويروح
للرضيع فهو يمكن بشوف الام والابن انه هم
عندهم علاقتهم بحس حاله هو كشخص خارجي زي
اوت سايدر وممكن هذا يعمل عنده اكتئاب
وكمان قله النوم قله النوم بدون ما يكون
الواحد اب او ام بتعمل اكتئاب اكيد يعني
وبتطلع الواحد عن طاره
وسبب كان هو عاده يعني بحس انا المجتمع
بمليه علينا اللي هي توقعات دائما بقول لك
لما بصير عندك ولد او يوم ما تولد الام او
يعني للام او للزوج هذا احلى يوم بحياه
الام او الزواج هو بصراحه مش عند الكل
بصير هذا الشيء هو اكيد اكيد انها لحظه
حلوه بس هي لحظه جديده يعني ما بقدر احط
شعور حلو او شعور محزن هو اكيد شعور حلو
بس هي مش سعاده هي مش جديد ضحى انا خليتك
تاخذين راحتك بس خليني اقول لك العرب
كانوا يقولون بان الاولاد والمال مجبنه
الرجال الرجل يخاف حينما يكون لديه نقص في
المال لانه ما يستطيع دعم اسرته وكذلك
يخاف على اولاده من المستقبل فبالتالي قد
يكون هذا هو العامل الرئيس الخوف او انه
المراه يمكن في الجانب الاخر من يقول بانه
المراه في هذه الفتره تكون هي متقلبه
مزاجيا فتؤثر على الرجل سلبا بدا يحط الحق
علينا
لازم الزوجه شوي يعني يتحمل
ويكون هيك طويل البال وعنده حلم وصبر لانه
فعليا هي كمان مطلوب منها اشياء جسديه غير
غير النفسيه كمان
مش داخلين نتحمل مسؤوليه بعض انه اتحمل
مسؤوليه
ولا لا شوف كمان بعض الرجال بعض الرجال
بيدخلوا في اشي اسمه
انه هو بحس حاله انه هو مش على ما يرام او
حاسس حاله مكتئب وبنفس الوقت بصير عنده
احساس بالذنب انه انا ليش هيك حاسس انا
المفروض اكون سعيد
انا بقول انه كل واحد له دوره انت نام مو
ضروري تصحى بالليل
يعني
احنا نمزح يعني في الفتره الصباحيه
فبالتالي كل التقدير للامهات
والاباء دائما على على حق
والام دائما على حق ولكن بس هو الحياه
شراكه ولازم يعني المركب ما بيمشي الا اذا
الاثنين تضافروا وتساعدوا عليها انا مش
عارفه اذا ضل عندنا وقت ولا انتهى انتهى
وقتنا للاسف باول مركب اول محطه الله معك
شكرا جزيلا الك ضحى العوامله الاختصاصيه
النفسيه كانت معنا من عمان
[موسيقى]
حاله الاكتئاب اللي هي بعد بعد الطفل
الاول او بعد الخلفه عموما الاولانيه
بيكون طبعا اهتمام المراه الكبير بالمولود
بيبقى بتدي له اهتمام اكبر من الراجل
خلافه على كده ان طبعا الظروف الاقتصاديه
بيمر بها مش العرب بس ده العالم كله بيمر
بظروف اقتصاديه صعبه جدا يمكن من
المسؤوليه مثلا بيخاف من المسئوليه فعشان
كده بيحس ان هو مكتئب يعني كل واحد
المفروض ما بيخلي بيبقى اسعد لحظات حياته
لما بيخلف بيشوف ظهرت الدنيا اللي بيعمله
في الدنيا كله في ولاده واللي نفسه يعمله
كله بيعملوا لعياله وبيشقى في الدنيا دي
كلها عشان خاطر عياله اللي يخليه يجيله
صدمه ولا يجيله الكلام ده كله ده بالعكس
بتبقى احسن وافضل لحظات حياته اللي هو
بيعيشها في مسؤوليه وفي مصاريف وفي كل
حاجه وبيعمل حسابه ان هو جاي عليه الزمن
ومش هيعمل حاجه غير ان هو يصرف وياكل
ويشرب وياكلهم هيروح فين تاني غير كده هو
متفاعل خير في الدنيا
ما بتحصلش حاجه زي كده كتير يعني ده انا
بفرح جدا يعني لما قال اولاد ده والحمد
لله يعني ولو حصلت حاجه زي كده
من الشيطان الرجيم والحمد لله بكمل حياتي
الطبيعيه عادي يعني
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات